[Music]
want people to have [ __ ] jobs and
save money which is why I'm like hey
make third make 29k but live a 22k likes
so you save I want you to make 29k save
a thousand a year and work on your
[ __ ] dream your [ __ ] dream
everyone talks about [ __ ] dreams if
it's a [ __ ] dream you should bleed
out of your eyes if it's a [ __ ] dream
you should sweat for a decade
it's a [ __ ] dream people think dreams
are being handed out here like [ __ ]
candy you got your perspective
[Applause]
good morning it is Friday they're good
people they third it is good people day
we'll talk about that later good morning
everybody welcome to tea with Gary Vee I
am your host Gary Vaynerchuk okay Gary B
okay
a New York Jets fan who hates every
Patriot world feel good things are solid
a lot of operational stuff going on at
vaynermedia spending some time with fam
facetiming connecting with friends and
family and most of all really enjoying
this tremendous show first G shout out
to the person line group that's been
doing watch parties on this big shout
out to you guys thanks for watching
reddit Instagram Twitter Facebook
Linkedin all live this morning Dustin on
women's and ones and twos thank you for
that got my tea I'm ready for my
questions and as always screen sheet
this share on Twitter so that I can
follow and retweet you all along the
show during the in betweens get that
screen shot in right now share the
facebook URL share the facebook URL if
you're in it right now in the bottom
there hit that little share and or just
copy the URL and post it let's get your
homies in here Dustin let's get our
first first question in here good
morning how are you I'm great
I'm not I'm not drinking tea I'm
drinking coffee so I need to get back
but first I want to say thank you to
Justin and your entire team for giving
me this opportunity I was meet Justin
and go to vaynermedia in New York which
was great
hopefully you know I get to meet you one
day but a little bit about my background
is you know I graduated from Villanova
played basketball there and I was able
to generate a very large audience on my
Instagram platform
I got a verified blue check worked for
Baron Davis in LA was heavily in sports
production so my main question for you
is now that all of these new social
media platforms are opening up you have
tik-tok linked in snapchat
Facebook even how can i generate that
same large audience that I did on
Instagram on to all these other social
media platforms and then how can I kind
of focus my content to make sure that
I'm doing the same things that align on
these social media platforms so you
don't have to have you know on the last
part it's important to be contextual in
the room that you're in so make sure
your content is contextual to it right
like you on the basketball court during
your college years was the different you
than was in the classroom which was the
different you that when you went out
with your girls and turned up right so I
think a make sure that on tik-tok or
LinkedIn or Facebook or Instagram there
is a it's always you but it's a
different version of you different
adjectives different slightly different
content different post-production I
think you use your Instagram right now
so one of the strategies that I had when
I saw that Facebook fan pages were going
to get less organic reach about five
years ago was I said oh my god this is
not going to be the prime place anymore
so I'm gonna use this chapter this next
year which we nailed it I could see it
and we nailed it to build up all the
other platforms because this is where my
biggest base is that's what I think
people should be doing with their
Instagram right now you should be how
many times a day do you post on
Instagram main post I barely post but
every day on my story at least but even
just then down on me a little bit about
posting consistently yeah I mean I think
people have decided to use their main
Instagram feed like a [ __ ] gallery
right like it's got to be like this
perfect photo all this [ __ ] they
overthink it that's why they don't post
enough I think you should be posting two
times a day minimum just I think you
should be posting three times a day the
post you want and then one post to build
up your tick-tock like literally it's
your tick-tock and it's posted in your
Instagram and you're like yo follow me
on tick-tock
it's gonna get way less likes everyone's
a god it's not as many likes but
meanwhile in 24 months when organic
reach on Instagram is declining and
tick-tock is poppin you're gonna be
happy you did it right it's almost like
oh [ __ ] I was cool as [ __ ] in middle
school
but like you know then when you go to
high school it doesn't [ __ ] matter so
everybody who's been checked and five
hundred thousand followers on on
Instagram right now they could end up
being Dane Cook and Tila Tequila those
two [ __ ] dominated myspace for all
the old heads in here you know but you
know just cuz you were popping on
something for a minute doesn't mean it
doesn't change like being a contestant
American Idol season two and three meant
you were celebrity now not as much and
so things change so I would use your
Instagram right now to build up your
other social networks
yeah for sure I like everything together
one hard component that I kind of had to
deal with was when I left college I
couldn't sell Villanova anymore you know
what I mean there's pictures in my
uniform I'm no longer a basketball
player in this Villanova uniform so my
content sort of changed and I kind of
had it supposed to right it's a but yeah
and it's supposed to that's life right
like I get it
right like the cool thing is you ABAB
like all my all my content used to be
wine right and when I started wedding
and when I started wanting to talk about
business I had to start over mm-hmm
don't don't look at it as a negative
like [ __ ] I've lost this platform and
this and that or this fanbase a lot of
these people like the reality is you're
fortunate that you have that starting
base right the the entire game is based
on what you put out and if you're not
putting out main feed posts you're not
talking and if you're not talking you're
not being heard and if you're not being
heard you can't build attraction
connection and community mm-hmm as a
content creator it's hard to really
generate an audience when you move from
different platforms especially like
myself where I had to figure out alright
who's gonna be invested in to build of a
basketball anymore and I'm not even
there anymore so now I have to remember
me basketball what basketball did for me
opened up my outlets and and that's what
I'm working with now and then figuring
out what content to produce along the
way you need to post content as if
you're talking to your friends and
family you need to be thinking about
documenting not original creating like
you could take you could take a video
right now with with you know Kobe in the
back
and just tell people why you loved him
mm-hmm right hey listen to me everybody
over thinks content I can see it
everybody over thinks it it's not that
[ __ ] serious that's why people love
stories it disappears
because people are insecure the reason
people love stories is it's like oh you
know oh cool who gives a [ __ ] and then
they treat their [ __ ] Instagram
account like it's a museum right even
for me when I do business with companies
and products as a social-media
influencer you know they want to give me
that code and make me just post the
picture with the product and do it on my
story and I'm in a sense I see everybody
doing that those same marketing content
strategies and do they work to a certain
degree but what's gonna make you stand
out yeah and I think more importantly if
you're doing a discount code and you're
only getting paid by conversion that's
not something interesting because you're
giving up all the brand dollars right
you know and that's right you lose you
get seven people one sometimes zero
separate and psych [ __ ] they got all
that brand awareness but they only paid
you for the sales conversion listen to
me you need to rethink your whole thing
you need to post listen to me listen to
me really good you need to post three
times a day on Instagram right now your
heads up what the [ __ ] you talking about
I'm posting once every [ __ ] two weeks
and I'm like cool but I'm [ __ ]
telling you that's why you [ __ ] it up
this morning and asking me this question
like I'm telling you right now you need
to go there and you need to you you have
to attack tick-tock you have to and you
don't you know the [ __ ] dance you
have to [ __ ] put out whatever you
want to put out talk about transitions
and life you're going through transition
like it's coming out of your body you go
through a transition in life at seven
million people declared unemployment
last week they're all going through
transitions in life you know an ungodly
amount of people are 18 22 going through
a divorce starting a new business like
everyone's going through transitions in
life just [ __ ] speak your drink's
right that's what I'm that's what I'm
trying to do is stay genuine to myself
no I'm haven't because you've been using
the easy way out on stories you have to
[ __ ] post two to three times a day
on your main feed on Instagram I promise
you once you break that preciousness of
it it will [ __ ] change your game
right right now you're in the framework
of boring about the people on the other
side of the post you need to worry about
you that's right just been focused on
getting 30,000 likes on my pictures cuz
that's what I've been able to generate
and I need to move away from that listen
to me that means dog [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] right
why not 40,000 I have to admit I did
care at one point not the numbers they
did get good news everybody cares right
so you're not you know I would everybody
cares you know why everybody lives in
high school when they leave it right you
have to get the [ __ ] out of there yeah
and I'm obsessed with getting people out
of high school
I'm like hang on don't let go and go be
happy and talk about some [ __ ] you like
do you like do you like chess do you
like bananas do you like smoothies do
you like Dunkin Donuts coffee do you
like Kobe do you like checkers do you
like do you like your old friend Rick
from high school I just make [ __ ] mm-hmm
I'm telling you I'm telling you
six thousand likes six thousand likes on
a post that gets you a thousand
followers on tic-tock is way better than
50 posts in a row that give you 50,000
likes on Instagram for you right now I
can't understand I created my tick tock
probably in three weeks so far I already
have 40,000 followers and I'm not saying
ready ready I want two things for me I
want you posting two to three times this
is my prescription two to three times a
day on Instagram and never starting
sentences about social media predicated
on followers right even the insight of
like I already right you know where blue
check like right if you think about it
you're looking for outside validation
and you need to start the process of
inside game mm-hmm Wow right right I'm
gonna start posting more I got to good
good luck thank thank you Gary so much
so welcome be sure you do thank you that
was a big time one Dustin to started off
I think that just [ __ ] help with a
million people over the next ten years
that video circulates
and it's individuality let's keep this
going let's see what's going on on
Twitter people sharing the screenshots
there we go good job Nick Nick my man
I am your 80th follower Oh Sean Kelly's
in the building
hey Gary nice to meet you nice to meet
you
so I'm 23 I'm from New Jersey born and
raised actually living this got away
right now ten minutes let's go I used to
do I used to do the Piscataway oh no
that's cat away I used to do Piscataway
New Jersey Kyle like Kyle
Akira's name a jet player was drafted
from Piscataway New Jersey went to Boise
State he was a corner go ahead oh nice
yeah so I basically went to Rutgers
that's where I found you listen to you
all throughout freshman year so thank
you so much my question today basically
I host free monthly networking events in
New Jersey I really like to stress the
free factor and I make sure all my
speakers don't sell or pitch anything
I've been having them to past six months
was their first one at 28 people and
then our last one in February had 154
people so we've been growing slowly but
surely we were gonna have one in Miami
actually yesterday but with the corona
buys we had to cancel it yet about 300
people confirm for that one so I know
I'm onto something with these free
events Steve Rock was actually gonna
speak out on so yeah shout out to D Rock
my question to you is how can I turn
these profitable because we're not
profitable yet since they are free
sponsored I keep growing one sponsor one
clean sponsor I like what you're doing
the way make it profitable is you get
yet you get chase you get a say P you
get you know Oracle you get you know
Toyota you get one clean corporate
sponsor who wants access so what you do
is you make a deck of like who's coming
what's the demo of the people coming at
150 300 you start with a smaller
business I mean heck even Wine Library
if it's in New Jersey might want to
sponsor it and pay you you know at first
2,000 bucks to be a sponsor and serve
wine at the event you get one clean
sponsor that gets like two seconds like
just you know we're used you know you or
ever TMZ is like
big shout out to you know Wine Library
for sponsoring the event or let's get
going like literally not like a [ __ ]
disgusting like commercial just a clean
sponsor that wants access to the
audience one and the way you do that
right now is you make a video or a three
or four page deck that sums up what
you're up to and you just [ __ ] start
asking got it thank you so much and I
guess I further grow the audience
because everything up to this point has
been me cold DMing or cold emailing
people to come I pretty much do you
every day until I'm blocked but I guess
how can I run - ah yeah you could you
could run pay traffic but you know the
first marketing campaign I did for Wine
Library when I was a kid was print out
20% off a case of wine coupons on my
computer and then go to the Short Hills
Mall and put them on people's car
windows like you know like yeah like
like the big beginning is ghetto and
honestly one day you'll you'll reminisce
about the ghetto
you'll reminisce about the dirt you'll
reminisce about the beginning and so you
know you're doing it 28 you know 57 103
150 300 like the word of mouth will take
over content you know every time you're
doing a bed there should be 50 to 100
pieces of content on LinkedIn Instagram
Facebook Twitter you're probably not
doing enough post event content to spur
up awareness that's called branding and
so a weekly podcast that's tied into the
thing I mean right now I would probably
reach out to everybody that's ever spoke
and do some zoom and Google hangout and
Instagram lives with them like contents
the [ __ ] yet like you know it's crazy
it's kind of like no eat well and work
out eat well and work out like that's
how you get in shape and like I keep
talking about like how do you create
opportunities in business and I'm like
content content now just like in working
out I had to learn like pin back my
shoulders so I get my chest not my
shoulders when I work out Mike and
Jordan taught me that same reason I talk
about tick-tock this or Instagram that
or LinkedIn this like there is tactics
within it but always think content
you're not producing enough content for
awareness of these shows I promise that
thank you yeah I have videographers but
I'm not repurposing the content anywhere
so I need to start doing that guess what
you're [ __ ] stuck in home with
[ __ ] the corona pandemic outside so
you can [ __ ] make a thousand piece of
content from the four events right now
get into that post edit place got it
amazing yeah I got one final question if
you got the time with all this
coronavirus stuff and sports being
canceled how is vane or sports handling
all your athletes and everything going
on with that you know we have 13 kids
going into the draft and that's staying
real so we're very busy with that a lot
of our vets have signed their contracts
or under contract so they're chilling at
home and we're texting them to keep them
motivated make sure they're working out
you know in their playbook you know
they're professionals so you know the
majority of our kids one of the things
with banner sports is we're very focused
on the quality of the human and you know
98% of them are very capable of handling
their [ __ ] the grown men and so even the
youngest of the bunch so it's been
pretty cool and we're in football right
so they're they haven't missed anything
yet and so we're kind of okay for now
got it
let's see what's going on here some good
shaming going on Robert
it's a ballast Jr appreciate you Rob
Blake Thank You Todd social with the
nice little share by Green ich McHenry
you get a follow for that I am your 78th
follow Nick I'm just gonna ask you do
you drink wine wine text that's a
question for everybody here if you
drinking wine get on wine Tex Avery
what's good thanks for being on brother
what's good I'm good man I'm 23 years
old
I'm in college mechanical engineering
and my original dream was to come here
and design cars but like it's not
working out because it's just way too
much work and I realized there's all the
small details so at this point I know
but anyway I've taken a class called
exploring majors my last year I was
humming but anyway
my new dream is to link up this YouTube
channel where like go around and I would
ask he's like hey you want to go for
ride in my car and specifically I'd have
like a Guyardo or something and then I
talk about a talk with him and be like
hey what are you like goals and
ambitions in life but I'm just undecided
if this is like a reasonable dream to
pursue because I really just want to
motivate and inspire kids to be like hey
I want you to go out and do what you
want to do don't do what everybody's
telling you you do it or you like I want
to do it not because mom wants me to go
to college like is this like something
reasonable or is that like it's very
reasonable I mean yeah you just got to
make sure you don't get arrested for
trying to roll up on kids and say hey
get in my car but I'm sure they have
that prearranged of just Pleasant so
yeah I think it's super reasonable I
think Avery I think you just need to
realize that it's probably gonna be two
full years of you putting out videos on
YouTube before it pops and so can you
afford to like be in a place where
you're chasing that when you're not
making any money can you get a [ __ ]
job that pays you a little something to
maintain a little rent and a little food
like you know what's funny when I when I
hear people say it's my dream I always
it always catches my attention cuz I'm
like cuz I'm always like is it because
when I hear people say it's my dream
then I'm like oh this is gonna be easy
Avery for five years nothing Goods gonna
happen you're gonna work at 7-eleven or
or at an office or some [ __ ] just to pay
rent and food so that the other 7 hours
you can work on driving with Avery
nothing good is gonna happen for five
years you're not gonna be [ __ ] Gary B
you're not gonna [ __ ] pop you're not
gonna make money you're not and it's
your like that then it is your dream and
let's go yes it's but if so all you need
to do is find animate and this is a big
big shout out to everybody's got a dream
the number one way as a young person to
win on a dream is to find a [ __ ] job
that doesn't take up a lot of time let
me say one more time because it's
confusing as [ __ ] the way you actually
because if you went right out of school
and started doing this and you had a
couple of dollars saved up and you and
your couch servant or your parents are
paying for it or whatever cool but guess
what it's only gonna last
two or three months cuz you're not gonna
everyone's like oh by month six I'll be
making $100,000 on ads on YouTube it
never happens so the way to actually
live a dream usually is for that dream
to be your side hustle but takes up all
your free time cuz it's your dream now
right it's not a kinda it's your dream
now you know it takes away from 2k takes
away from hanging with your voice it
takes away from having a girlfriend
boyfriend it takes away from [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] dream the way to [ __ ] have a
dream is for you what I'm listening
maybe you get a job as you know at a car
business because you [ __ ] with them
right like maybe if I can work at maybe
you're a [ __ ] Adam you're a
receptionist at a [ __ ] car dealership
no I did that I swear I worked at
Mitsubishi I was the receptionist
I was the valet I worked in parts like
I've done all this car stuff I've been
around people I'm definitely a people
person which is why I feel like I have
to do this as I want people to be like I
can do it like everybody Avery could get
a job at a school that pays for you to
be able to have a roof and eat clearly
not the kind of job that's gonna give
you a mansion and caviar the kind of job
that's gonna give you bogles and three
roommates right and then you have six
hours seven hours a day to [ __ ] do
your dream it's very feasible is the
concept right
you know the concept right [ __ ] the
coffee with [ __ ] comedians Seinfeld
[ __ ] you've seen this already of course
it's feasible it's just going to come
down to how talented you are
I just wasn't sure if like that but I
wasn't sure if you were gonna suggest
like a podcast or like do something else
besides like oh good news when you do
the Lambo and go for a ride hey you
gotta figure out how you're gonna get
these cars but you know that I have a
feeling you try to figure that out but
engineering but yep but you strip the
audio and you make it a podcast so you
film it you make it my podcast is a top
200 podcast in the world and I never sit
down I mean rarely sit down and actually
do a podcast it's just a script audio
from should I do like this okay how's it
makes it
I can roll that the framework Avery is
side job to pay for you to chase your
dream for a long time yes I was gonna do
after graduation I $70,000 it's called a
good thanks man I love that good luck
pleasure good kid
people jump into their dream Dustin and
have no money have no savings have no
reserves and have to quit after five
weeks cuz miraculously they didn't
become [ __ ] Kevin Hart after two
videos about humor what they need to do
is get that [ __ ] job especially the
car the reason I like receptionist and
others [ __ ] like that is I get me a job
that actually lets me be on my phone six
of the seven hours as long as I'm taking
care of the inbound so I can even keep
pumping my [ __ ] that pays I get two
roommates I have a roof I want people to
have [ __ ] jobs and save money which
is why I'm like hey make 30 May 29 K but
live a 22 K likes so you save right and
some BC taxes whatever like you people
get the point I want you to make 29k
save a thousand a year and work on your
[ __ ] dream your [ __ ] dream
everyone talks about [ __ ] dreams if
it's a [ __ ] dream you should bleed
out of your eyes if it's a [ __ ] dream
you should sweat for a decade it's a
[ __ ] dream people think dreams are
being handed out here like [ __ ] candy
why are you good what's your name Carla
so nice to me do so I'm a contact grader
in Instagram I open my Instagram about
food years ago I started my business in
nursery the Cole my background is
engineering I used to work for the city
as a civil engineer my husband was an
architect and he quit his job we wanted
to spend more time with family so we
both quit our job and now we're working
full-time from home so one of the
questions I guess that I have because
you know every platform is obviously
different
we got a huge success on Instagram but
we're trying to replicate the business
on tik-tok so how do you come and you
reach to dicta because you know like I
mean I'm 38 years old
so I mean I you know my crowd is a
little bit different
and message that I have is different
iDate trade I have like a lot of like
different experience so to me is kind of
fun to do you know like there's a
content creator you're doing silly
photos with your kid move that but as a
business how can you you know be able to
like monetize that so what you need to
do is you need to be you on that
platform and wait for the platform to
get older and wider so I'm 44 years old
and doing plenty well on tik-tok because
two years ago or 18 months ago I just
made the content that I make and so the
biggest mistake that people make is they
go into tick-tock and they think they
have to do dances they think they have
to do what works on tick tock what they
need to do is talk about what works for
you I want you to make a date trading
tick tock an information one minute
about day trading now it may not get as
many views at first but I don't know how
early you got an Instagram but at first
Instagram was just for photographers
it wasn't about personalities
it wasn't about business it wasn't about
motivation it wasn't that humor it
wasn't about you know people looking
good it was just about photography and
then it changed
Twitter was just about technology nerds
talking about tech and web 2.0 and then
it changed so you need to go on tic toc
and be you and let the platform and the
audience evolved into you not you
conforming to the platform you just need
a little patience understand how about
LinkedIn listening to you I think
LinkedIn could be a tremendous place
because of your back engineering
architecture of a training I think
LinkedIn could be an incredible place
it'll be a little bit slower it'll be
more business but I think it could be an
incredible place for you guys to
consider - I'm very bullish on LinkedIn
what about you - always YouTube is like
oxygen
anybody who's creating content needs to
go on YouTube the reason instagramers
don't like youtube is it takes a lot
more work and it's a lot slower and
everybody got excited about how simple
it was to just take a photo or a quick
video and grow quickly on Instagram it
takes a lot more creativity and a lot
more patience and a lot more work to
grow on YouTube but it is a very top
important platform in the world do you
think is important to post like maybe
twice or three times a day on Instagram
I'm currently only posting once I do
okay I think you're missing out an
opportunity and I'm sure you've already
seen from - how long have you been on
Instagram yes - so have you noticed even
the last six months that the posts are
declining or you throw it is mix
sometimes it deployed based on the
content so when I'm posting more with
the kid because people are seeing more
of my life I get more likes if it's more
like like me by myself is less like so
it's not good
so I think you're missing opportunity I
think you should be posting two to three
times today's 100,000%
okay all right good luck :
thank you take care so much
tea with Gary Dean 30 minutes in a lot
of fire I appreciate people that are
sharing I appreciate everybody who's
sharing really do
I really do thank you Michael
tea with Mike I like your handle yeah
Tristan I like the book people really
responding to the dreams conversation on
Twitter which I appreciate maryanne
strategy got us I appreciate that you're
gonna follow Marian $194 oh hi hi good
morning good morning what's your name
how musicians and artists utilize
LinkedIn because I hear talking about
all the time and I'm confused because I
use you know YouTube and tik-tok
Instagram but like I don't know how do
you did you did you ever use Facebook do
you ever have a Facebook page
what was that before your time yes it's
changed but did you ever have did you
ever have it and it was working back 4
or 5 3 4 years ago when it was popping
kind of cuz I've only been doing my
music stuff for a really short time
where I focus at it no like I don't
think I was in the time where I could
have utilized it children you have
YouTube yes and that's working where you
like it it's growing doing it okay so
LinkedIn is much more similar to YouTube
and Facebook like literally you put a
long-form video in there and you just
post it LinkedIn is literally Facebook
70 years ago
literally like you don't have to make it
about business you can literally push
the picture of a cat and be like my cat
Rick and today it's it's a it's a social
network now on top of just being a
resume and business place and I'm just
and it has a lot of organic reach early
and so an early tick-tock early snapchat
early favor Lee it's real estate
anything early where there's attention
and not enough content is a great place
for all of us because literally you just
literally you just post a two-minute
video of your music on there and you
write some copy of like hey here's where
you can be smart hey take a break from
your workday and then you enjoy this
song about birds or love whatever I
think you'd be very surprised what
happens in there
that's it that's it okay because I was
always like a resume for working a desk
job I guess it's not it's a it says it's
become a content social network that's
acting a lot more like Facebook did
seven years ago literally I'm watching
post about why and I watch people post
about you know exercise like it's a it's
a very very effective platform and what
I like about it is you go there day one
nobody's ever heard of you you have no
followers and you post and you have 137
people watch your video it's getting
free organic reach and so many people
watching right now don't have the money
to launch a brand which is why I
constantly talk about organic platforms
like tick tock and LinkedIn because you
can start with zero cents and build your
life oh yeah six knocks and crazy
because I went on there and within like
four videos I had like six hundred eight
hundred use on one stupid video and I I
don't have anything that's right how
many times day are you posting on
tik-tok probably once every two days
it's not every day I think you need to
really post two to three times a day on
tick tock especially paying to music
because you're you're wasting away the
time where there's free organic reach
and in four years you're gonna and in 12
months you're gonna be sad being and
post three times a day
agreed I think so awesome thank you so
much
Tom what's good oh my gosh this is crazy
I'm a huge fan
[Music]
try not to be nervous but like man bro
you've helped me through so much like
thank you I can't thank you enough Barry
this is this is just crazy for me so my
questions coming into question yeah
before you get into question what um
what did I help you most with and what
was the piece of content or what was the
constant theme there's so much Gary I
mean mainly tik-tok I was doing
Instagram I was doing snapchat I was
doing LinkedIn I was doing all these
platforms but they just weren't really
like hobbies they weren't really
exploding and I was posting content but
take talk I went on it's in September I
heard you talking about I'm like okay
Gary saw I'm at six not so much let me
do it and so I've been posting
three times a day and now I've like
40,000 followers I'm talking about
aviation Airlines stuff like it's just
crazy I'm not even busy dancing stuff
like I'm just providing value and now
I've made so many connections of people
um it's it's really crazy and I do these
lives where like I just go live with
people like right now I'm taking the
vidiians at the 14th I'm and I just go
on there and talk to them and try and
provide value that you talk about and it
really hits home with them poster truck
keep it going to them my question is is
how do i monetize on tik-tok without
like trying to sell like I have your
marketing side that I just you know I
just don't like selling but these people
like these kids keep on asking me like
how do I invest in you because my dream
is to start my own airline just like how
you're trying to size New York Jets my
dream is to start my own airline how do
I invest unless Richie Rich is following
you on tick-tock these kids aren't gonna
have enough money to really pop you up
anyway you know what I'd probably do I'd
probably create oh I probably draw I'm
not even kidding
I'd probably draw or have a design
friend create a logo of your future
airline right and create you know and
create a hoodie and it like a beanie and
a cap and like and and see it's like the
audience wants to get on it'd be really
cool if you did something and instead
coming 20:47 you know did something cool
like that you could have some fun with
merch on that I also would tell you that
if you don't need to monetize the
audience don't I have continuously not
monetized my audience around my subject
matter
obviously I've started businesses like
empathy wines and did a collaboration
with k-swiss where I'll bring awareness
to things I've done but I've never
directly monetized my audience and I
always tell people if you don't need to
don't for as long as humanly possible
because it gives you such a better
chance to actually build a real
relationship and then by the time you
know most people who are watching right
now that are signing up or wine text are
doing it because they know that it means
a lot to me to help my dad right and so
I would I would uh I would tell you
don't if you can
and if you and if you can't and you
really need money then I would consider
swag based on the story I heard of the
future brand which I think could be
really cool well I said with them would
fit the tic-tock audience like buying a
twenty dollar beanie with some rad
[ __ ] outline of an airline like
that's that seems like realistic versus
taking funding from crowdsourcing to you
know invest in your future airline
that's 37 years away yeah and I tell my
fans you know they're like wonder when
you start your line I said like 2017
like it's all about the process like I'm
not I'm not about to go rush in and
started freaking airline like so early
like there's so much capital to that and
there's actually they've actually
started like a fan account and some of
them are like making their own liveries
and things like that and like I'm just
really gonna post on my tick-tock it's
just crazy the community that I built up
there it's true organic it's true like
built up and it's just it's it's really
crazy and I'll take your advice I've
been joking about merch but I noticed
you don't really like to do much like
every time not do thank you I pull
around with it I I you know I do merch
once in a blue moon to test theories I
like learn you know 137 p.m. the male
media said I have I want to do a ton of
merch there so I've been using you know
some of the hoodies and different things
I've done on my community or my world
have been one offs limited edition I
mainly make them so that my fans can buy
them and then we flip them on eBay and
make money but uh yeah go play Tom I I'm
really happy for you man you sound real
happy and that makes me happy so keep
doing I am her I am birthday so much
you're welcome good kid like the [ __ ]
you know what's really fun about all
this Dustin is like in 39 years watching
a video like the kid really goes and
builds it and then you can recall this
video you know that [ __ ] that shit's
crazy yeah Facebook 5700 you let's share
the [ __ ] out of the URL go to the top
right now go to the bottom if you're on
mobile and hit that little share button
in the bottom left hand corner if you're
on desktop go to the top right now
control C control see that URL and in
post gets up here yeah Tony what's good
Oh
how are you eat this morning I'm really
well who's this little beautiful one
this is Saoirse this is my youngest of
three good morning to you like I said I
have three kids and my oldest is 15 he's
actually sitting next to me he is
extraordinary
not because I'm his mother and he's my
child but ever since he was little his
like from the first time he could start
talking he his motto was cash-only so
this kid is just amazing he tries to
make a business out of anything living
over there always thinking about how can
I make money how can I help my parents
how can I you know think about my future
cuz I don't know maybe he gets it from
me and his dad but he is exceptional in
a lot of things and guys he agrees um so
as a parent you know I really want to
encourage him with all of the things
that you stood at and that he wants to
pursue in the future but he's 15 so do I
encourage everything or do I pick and
choose a few things that you know like
Meech things that he's really really
exceptional at neither
you know you you you don't do anything
other than cultivate the framework you
picking things for him is not a good
strategy in my opinion I think what you
need to do is give him protection to
find his way and so good news you're
talking about a kid that sounds a lot
like me right and so I think liking a
lot of things is a good thing because
he's tasting he's learning you
understand if he does seven different
businesses between 15 and 18 right now
and they all failed that's actually a
huge win for a kid that's wired like
that in the same way that it was for me
the losses the things that didn't work
are the reason I became successful and
it's having that freedom to start
Pizza shop to start a hotdog stand to
start a lawnmower business to start
flipping to start a sneaker flipping to
like it's all that he needs to taste
continue to taste that's a huge huge
that is so much more valuable if you
told me his next three years was he did
eleven things and only made eight
hundred thirty dollars or he could have
done one thing and made ninety thousand
I actually believe a somewhat I'm
listening to you that the eleven eight
thirty is better okay because he's a
child
he's got his whole life in front of him
I know he looked and the more he learns
about himself right now and the and his
interests the more he's gonna be able to
build on that when he gets into
primetime wonderful okay and he he has
his own mini business it's called wooden
wires and he does electronic repair he
builds computers he does all sorts of
anything with electronics really and he
does these little like reviews almost
products that he uses what's the one
like that it's like a glue or a heat
glue okay so he did this little thing
I'm the thermal paste that he uses when
he builds his computers on YouTube yeah
my company reach out Instagram
text reviews on Instagram
I guess well the company actually saw it
and they used it like shared it and was
like hey this is awesome how do I get
him to understand the value of
sponsorship
I mean he's 15 he all he needs to do is
reach out to them say hey I really like
your products I saw that you retweeted
or you know share I let his name blazed
hey blaze do you want to reach out to
brands and do that tell me the truth
don't be scared I don't know if I have
much to bring to that company well
definitely don't do that because the
reality is to your mom's point if the
company's already shared one of your
it's likely that your communication
style is bringing value it's not that
your you might not have a big audience
but which means it might not be an
awareness play but the quality the
content is so strong and that is the
value yes does that make sense please
yeah I I think
look here's please let me teach you
another great business lesson at this
age and and listen to your mom get here
on camera don't ever ever ever ever say
no for the other guy you know please
it's a big deal like one of the biggest
things blaze that I see a lot of people
do is say no for them before they've
asked right so you're saying I don't
know I wouldn't do this if I were the
amount of times people have paid me for
things that I would not pay for is every
time because I wouldn't pay for anything
cause I don't like don't overthink it
never ever ever please say no for the
other person before you ask
and it's listen please do not
underestimate the fact that that company
or pace company used that piece of
content it just might mean that you
really know your [ __ ] he does please
anything else I can answer for you that
might be on your mind while we're here
no not really
all right good luck thank you so much
you're welcome bye - man please quiet
introverted entrepreneur killer I can't
wait to see that kid above that was a
really good lesson for everybody do not
say no to the other person enough with
this insecure [ __ ] like you know you
know how you something Dustin you know
how you walk around the world and you
see like two people and like one's way
more attractive than the other person
you're like how the [ __ ] did that happen
but like you know like like that's
because that person didn't say no for
the other person right there's people
that close deals that make no [ __ ]
sense vaynermedia had no money I had no
money when I started vaynermedia cuz I
didn't have a lot of money building the
wine business and then what I did have I
just invested in Facebook
Twitter so we have no money that's why
we started in a conference room in
another company our first client you
know what we pitched them was not
something I would have bought with
Procter and Gamble Gillette razors like
but they bought it they needed it and so
like I don't get the judge you know um
and so that's the game that is the
[ __ ] game never say no for the other
person mother [ __ ] big principle for
me Jesus you know a Brants thank you so
much
where she'll scrub out John I'm gonna
buy some wine as it took into my
appreciation but I don't like wine which
have to be done John Cameron by the
rose' you'll be surprised how much you
like it I pumped it with sugar so it's
just straight delicious kenobi 70 with
me let's share him oh I'm sorry
Isaac hey Gary how's it going man super
well how are you doing very well every
day above ground is a good day right
I'm a believer in that [ __ ] right so hey
thanks for taking my call man appreciate
everything you do you're super highly
motivated well I really really
appreciate it
so thank you content out every to every
chance I get because you speak the truth
man
thank you brother well my question is
yes here he goes my dilemma is my mind
feels like it's going in every single
direction all the time my wife puts it
the best way is it's like a junk drawer
in your kitchen on a trampoline like
that so by the way you know who else is
like that this guy yeah she's like you
guys stupid
it's called being creative yes that's
what she said she got a very creative
mind and the problem is is like I have
I'll have something going it feels like
you have momentum going on then all
sudden [ __ ] squirrel right like oh my
god I've got this other idea that I
wanted nice yes Isaac have you ever
thought that the concept of being happy
is cooler than making money oh yeah a
hundred percent good if you actually
believe that then this conversation is
over
yeah well the prop see you're here the
thing is is I'm gonna reel
State and and you know another one of my
hobbies that I absolutely love to do so
I usually will kill it the first part of
the year and the second part of the year
I'm in the mountains about 3 or 4 months
out of the year s'okay content for that
because that's my passion I really love
doing that but also I really love
helping people get into their houses
also first time home ok so your wife is
like hey dick stop doing the [ __ ]
Mountain House [ __ ] cuz if you just
focused on real estate you'd make twice
the money no she's very supportive
actually she she great let's doing it so
so what's the problem
so my problem is I'll get a project
going and it's such a great idea that
everybody's like why don't you keep
going with that idea you don't want to
and another idea pops up and I start
doing something else
Isak uh seven years ago I could raise
the five hundred million dollar fund
made ten million dollars a year just to
take meetings and got 20% of the back
end of any deal that one if I had
invested properly I could have been a
monster venture capitalist I could have
made Bank because I invested in Facebook
Twitter Tumblr I became garyvee like I
had juice I juice there was family
offices billionaires throwing money I
mean take 50 million take ten million
like I could have build a huge fun again
for everybody doesn't know how a venture
capitalist phone runs is the businesses
you get 2% to manage the money and you
get 20% of the back end of any of the
profits and if you raise five hundred
million dollars you know or you know you
can make up at two percent you can make
you know ten million dollars a year just
taking meetings and doling out money and
had all the backend I didn't do it cuz I
didn't want to write because I actually
live my life the way I talk about it
which is happiness over cash yeah yeah
and I my my whole point is I like to
create there provide value to somebody
especially like right now during the
real estate time love there's a lot of
uncertainty you in a lot of people's
mind so you know just creating that
value to Isaac Isaac one day one day and
if I have anything to do with it sooner
than later one day
we as humans are gonna change the word
success to mean happy not rich and when
that happens you're gonna tell your
friends hey why don't you make doing
that job that has 400,000 but you're
drinking alcohol every night because
you're actually unhappy yes Isaac I
think you're winning and people that are
straight that want you to just pick one
thing and stay focused can go [ __ ]
themselves right exactly you know are
you happy I'm extremely happy are you
paying your bills
I'd be happy are you paying your bills
oh yeah you're [ __ ] winning I've
never had a problem paying my bills ever
so I know you're in the dust everyone
yeah sorry you know during the last real
estate downturn you know my wife and I
we took a little hiatus and we traveled
her and we did roadside sells you know
selling blankets on the side of the
street see you did you save some money
prior to that collapse we did not
unfortunately have you saved have you
saved some money this time around yep
one of the biggest reasons I'm happy I'm
very devastated about Korona one of the
small subtle nice things that's gonna
happen from this is a lot of people
gonna learn their first punch in a face
and over the next decade they will save
a little money yeah so so that when
something happens in 13 years
that's unfortunate they'll be prepared
yeah Isaac I see nothing wrong here I
see everything right awesome I want you
to start I want you to start a project
in business every three months and then
[ __ ] throw it to the garbage cuz you
scratched your itch one thing you could
consider Isaac one thing you could
consider instead of shutting them down
is bringing in a partner that you give
50 percent to to be the operator and
then you're getting some potential
passive income
nothing's passive I talk about that cuz
that person could quit you'll always
have to be on but you could extract
value out of some of these ideas and
projects by finding people to run them
and if you really take the worst-case
scenario and say okay I'm gonna bring
Susan in we're gonna be 50/50 seasons
gonna quit after six months and start
her own version of it because she's
gonna get upset that I'm no longer doing
anything as long as you're okay
which I love thinking worst-case
scenario then you could be a really
great spot okay
see I'm going yeah yeah like well like
one for example especially right now
since there's you know self isolations
going on is a few years ago or a couple
years ago during like periscope boom and
all that blab and all that stuff is you
remember you know I started a platform
home tours live and so and the problem
that I had is a lot of people had a hard
time going live because that fear of
public speaking essentially so and
that's that's that's one of the ideas
that I had before and I'm like oh maybe
I could it's a great time to read launch
that essentially try though
yeah try right now hang up and try yeah
well tell you super daddy appreciate it
take care of it thank you
keeps going what's happening on Twitter
Dustin we keep it keep going
here we go Tyson's in the building Tyson
how are you good Gary are you doing
really well hey man I want to take this
opportunity to say thank you for
everything that you do man I mean you
got a great message out there and speak
a lot of truth and I really appreciate
everything that you do thank you for
saying that sir so just to kind of jump
straight in give you a little bit of
context I spent the last probably I got
three kids I spent the last five or six
years I coach a lot of baseball for
youth baseball and I'm kinda at the
limit now to where my older son he's out
of my skill set to what I could teach
him anything anymore he's in a more
competitive landscape now doing travel
baseball he's for like the last year my
daughter also does a competitive
cheerleading as well so over the last
year I've done a lot of networking got
to meet a lot of like club owners club
presidents facility managers facility
owners so I've got a few friends that
own training facilities and teams in the
Sacramento California area so understood
so right now this is typically the time
of the year where we would be doing all
the advertising trying to recruit
bringing new athletes and things like
that so being that we don't really have
the normal traditional avenues that
we've had in the past
we're trying to adapt and I'm working
with some of the owners of some options
that we have so I've talked to him about
doing Instagram story ads running
Facebook ads and we're trying to target
you know more on the Instagram side
we're aiming more towards the athlete
age kids whereas Facebook ran more
towards the parents unlike anything I'm
hearing what's that
I like everything I'm hearing thank you
appreciate that
but I've also heard you talk in the past
about influence or marketing as well and
how it's under priced pretty potentially
new and underused yeah potentially so I
wanted to see is there anything we can
do to tie influencer marketing in and a
more localized region or is that more
for like hard it's a because your
business is so local you're gonna you're
gonna need to steal an influencer so
much so that you're okay with the
residual 4% of the audience that lives
in your general area and then you need
to repurpose that person's video in your
own channels maybe for a cosign so I do
think former professional baseball
players for example you know don't have
a big market so I could definitely see
you know former Sacramento Kings you
know you know ironically Chris Webber
vlade divac's you know you know are very
under priced so you might be able to
extract some Sacramento King stuff you
might be able to focus on some angels
and Dodgers that are retired for for
some stuff that might over resonate
because they were popular in the general
region but when you're localized
influence or marketing has to be hyper
local influencers which often times mate
you know for a business as nice as what
you're talking about for Wine Library a
local mom influencer in a New Jersey
suburb works for you it's so narrow that
that it might be a little bit of a
challenge but I would still test it I
would still you know reach out to 15
alpha moms in the Sacramento High Net
Worth neighborhoods region and say you
know can we make a piece of content and
see if it hits the parents and leads to
business JIT the answers never know you
always have to spend 500 to a thousand
when you can afford it to try some [ __ ]
okay I've heard you talk about the Alpha
mom thing in the past too and I think
I'm a big fan of the Alpha mom
especially when it goes to more like the
cheer side of things to where you know
maybe they chant 20 years ago I think
that could be a huge impacting as well
so yeah one of my friends over at Davis
Sports Academy they they have a lot of
friends that have played baseball in the
past and you know this is probably about
20 years ago they were in the game too
so they might have some connections
there we might be yeah and you'd be
surprised how cheap Vernon Wells or
Chris Iannetta or like you know you
could really you could really steal so
you know five hundred I mean they're not
they're not getting deals baseball
players are not Mike trout's not getting
enough deals let alone a retired
baseball from 20 years ago
and on a on a California baseball team
so I would consider that heavily okay
and that's kind of more the short-term
gear that we're heading towards but I'm
a long-term thing for branding you know
trying to aim for the kids that maybe
three four or five years from now might
be looking for teams what would you
suggest the avenues that we take 4 take
Talk Talk you can start a 12 year old
age oh my god what a [ __ ] dream tick
tock I would be putting out three
baseball the instructional or cheer
instructional videos a day okay perfect
I mean the cheerleading business on
tick-tock is [ __ ] layup City it's
huge huge we went to a you know
Indianapolis here just it back in
January and it's crazy you got I think
we had a horse towards 10,000 athletes
10,000 cheerleaders never met each other
and they're just jumping in meeting each
other jumping each other's videos
walking by and then jumping in you know
it's crazy I guess this really nice
little network for their age right there
100%
thank you brother awesome talk to you in
it thanks
keep this going
look at their Alfa Moms Christi good job
holding good
appreciate it Winston Alexander's
inability Naples April Prescott's got
her got her routine down I am your 50th
follower April big shout out to Edmonton
Gerald what's good what's good Gary man
is so good to see you man I absolutely
love what you do
everybody said man I've been a fan ever
since watching Wine Library thank you I
am an old-school og og where do you live
I live in Charleston South Carolina I
can spit into the Atlantic Ocean love
what I do and love where I live I'm a
southern boy born and bred
born and bred man I love it hey I got a
question for you now I'll give you a
little background about what I do I'm a
financial planner and I'm an insurance
broker that's what I do and I have a
two-part question about what I do right
now
my business is exploded I'm not
complaining about my business my
business has actually exploded since the
viruses since we've been in this social
distancing because we pivoted as you
talked about for so many times you gotta
be prepared to pivot and we pivoted
straight in social media so that's what
we've done but here's my question
personally in my business we're hyper
competitive my business is hyper
competitive it's all about the numbers
it's all about what you do and I have a
service mentality I just think that's
just how I roll
I really don't care about how much
numbers we do I don't care about the
dollars and cents but I get reflected on
in by my colleagues because I'm not
competitive and it comes off oftentimes
as if I'm living beneath my potential
and I'm holding my team back you're
wrong you're wrong you're listening to
people that aren't wired like you
gotcha catchin your plane you're playing
a much smarter game they're going for
fast nickels you're going for slow dimes
thank you brother
that's that's what I needed and I got I
got one more question about my business
my business is based we I don't even
like to use the word sell we actually
give back to the people and let them
make a decision based up but everybody
makes a decision based on emotion yes
this is what my business is savings with
me because of an emotion it's not about
it's um it's it's why you're winning cuz
you're playing on the gray and the
people around you are playing in the
black and white gotcha gotcha well
here's the thing I'm getting a lot of
pushback and a lot of my agents are
coming back to me now saying hey if we
push those emotional buttons and we push
those buttons at this time we're getting
some pushback because people are saying
that with fear-mongering and I mean look
I mean when you're by insurance by
nature is fear-mongering okay yeah it's
the nature of the beast like like like
like people buy 90% of things people do
and buy is based on fear how do you
change it you change a couple adjectives
you say it's slightly differently you
say upfront listen I'm sorry but that
the nature of insurance is a little bit
about fear that's just the punchline now
let me give you this the facts right I
get I get a lot of I often get people
saying that I sound a lot like you
because I just give the straight facts
I'm like look there's nobody that's
leaving here a lot so I mean have up
yeah no you're not leaving here alive
so if you love this woman that sitting
next to you Harold I'm trying to figure
it out though I'm some real [ __ ] don't
tell anybody but I'm trying to listen I
heard you in the cryogenics man I heard
but I
to live forever actually is to post
content for every single day at scopa
that's how you actually live forever
anyway listen listen I think you know if
I'm pitching life insurance I'm sitting
there too and I'm looking at mr. and
mrs. Johnson too and I'm saying look
you're gonna die and you probably you
probably don't want Uncle Sam to get
this money you probably want Wanda to
get this money right I mean it's just
real talk it's just real talk you know
like you know I I think that I do think
it's how you deliver I mean look
my intuition is that is that you are a
good salesman you just do it differently
and I think if you if you feel like you
might be bleeding a hair into
fear-mongering it just mix it up listen
I've I've adjusted hmm the way I
communicate always I'm always ready to
pivot in 2008 when the economy was
getting destroyed and everybody was
worried I loved the word hustle right
right and I loved it and I talked about
it and I loved it because I believe in
hard work I believe in it more than
anything in the world
I believe it's controllable and I
believe it's you that's that's you you
know your chemicals who your mama was
that's not you
hard work is you but then as things got
fluffy and things got good and the world
got good and everybody had enough money
all of a sudden in the culture the word
hustle became bad and it led to burnout
and it led to mental unhappiness and I
was like [ __ ] I need to I need to pivot
because the context changed and now I
use the word hard work a lot more than
the word hustle though I'm not scared of
it obviously and so and so that's what
you may need to do you mean need to
tweak it so it doesn't feel like you're
trying to scare mr. Jones into it you
see where I'm going
yeah and so so I'm living that I'm
living that around my favorite thing in
the world which is hard work and guess
what hard work and hustle is about to
get popular again because seven million
people work for unemployment last week
like you know all right I swear it is
thank you so much welcome and
appreciated all right so much
Tim garyvee I really like that clip
let's get that clip expedited that's
slow that's slow dimes versus fast
nickels I see it every day
you know III I lived that life the
journals of them I get so many people
they're like you're leaving so much
money on TV even so much money do this
do this it's back to the theme of this
this episode you know I'd rather be
happy than have more money and by the
way the happier are and the more you're
doing yourself you have a funny way of
ending up with more money in the end
than the people that are just doing it
for the [ __ ] cash
robbing [ __ ] gems this morning Dustin
and Twitter saying it there is so much
going on Natalie Pinder sharing it and I
got to give her some love you sure you
share the Twitter feed you getting some
automatic automatic Hugh says this is
the best time type of tea and I agree
Gina what is good how are you Gina can
you hear me I sure can
so my question my original question was
I'm an artist so I'm a commercial artist
I built my business around creativity
and creating and I have a passion for
art and I have a passion for expressing
myself creatively I've always done that
but also I have a real big passion for
people and I love how so so you know
this is we found like a perfect way to
kind of blend the two well so as as much
as I love doing what I do and I mean I
love it because I know and this is a
perfect episode for me to be on because
you you mentioned you know it's all
about how I am you know that's what's so
happy Gina Gina you won Regina listen to
me i I've lived the life that has taken
me to a place where I know a lot of very
wealthy people and 95% of them are super
sad oh yeah I I know wants that why do
you want our sad like you want to have a
Bentley and a mansion and be sad and
like cry and you're like and people
every time I bring up this anything like
this the comments go crazy like [ __ ] it
I'll take a Bentley you know like you
know and people just think things bring
happiness they're so [ __ ] confused
well I think it's so right so then how
do so we connect with a lot of people
you know our our client we have a wide
range of clients and and we work with
small businesses and because I love the
whole mentality of somebody kind of
diving in and starting a business and
you know what they'd love to do so and
then we also have larger scale clients
you know where we we do kind of like
this creative
lifestyle creative directions so if I'm
if somebody hires us to let's say
decorate their home or something right
you know and then they'll see because I
can I can I really can read what a
person does and I understand his
aesthetic of emotional you have the
emotional intelligence okay elgyn that
transcends right so then we do we do a
bunch of other stuff we'll help them
with Instagram content or you know
social media content and all this other
side but here's my question is I love
doing it so much okay how do I and I
also understand that I'm always gonna be
full of ideas and and and I understand
the whole premise of abundance how do i
how do I charge somebody and and how do
I I know how to charge right I know how
do I know how to I know how to but
sometimes I feel like [ __ ] I don't think
I'm charging enough I don't ask for more
it can advantage on your not being a
take advantage of you're the one who's
in control I hate when people do this
that I can take advantage I love you for
it
and I'm compassionate to it I hate it
because I love people so much I don't
want them to beat themselves up how can
you be taken advantage of when you
[ __ ] quoted the price I know you know
you're not being taken advantage of you
just don't have a pricing strategy that
you feel comfortable with yet people
everything everybody makes it a [ __ ]
soap opera and some [ __ ] Melrose
Place and dynasty [ __ ] like this is like
you know being taken advantage of by
Rick you sent $280 you know she's at
five thousand now five thousand our it's
a very simple game Eliza right I guess
it's like when people try to negotiate
it's like this is you can no no no no no
negotiating is fair you need to have the
[ __ ] balls to walk away and say no I
do well I think I have nothing I do
people people negotiate with me all the
time like no Gary Vee I'm not paying a
hundred fifty thousand dollars for you
to give this speech I got 70 K for you
I'm like no all right but 70 K to give
the speech is so much of like I don't
want it I'm gonna stay home and work
I'm gonna go to the judge what like like
negotiating don't be mad for somebody to
negotiate don't be mad at them pretty
good you said five thousand they said
three thousand like you're more than
welcome to take four thousand because
that's what they alluded to when they
said three thousand or you can say mr.
Smith I love you very much I'm gonna now
go talk to Jane because I have a list of
people that want to work with me and I'm
not taking less than five thousand and
very honestly I'm about to make it fifty
five hundred if you sit on it too long
right you just have to negotiate better
I know I think you're I think Tina let's
stay here you've got if you got the
stomach to walk you win yeah nobody
takes advantage of you when you say yes
for the money it means that you made a
decision that it was worth your time at
this moment to take less than what you
ideologically made let's just play it
out again what I'm worth I'm getting
taken advantage of
well why aren't you worth six thousand
instead of five thousand or 7,000 or
8,000 the way I grieve a new media and
my speaking career was to ask for more
every single time and then eventually
you get eight noes in her own you're
like okay [ __ ] it I might not be right
you know but you've got to be
comfortable with that gate and you got
to be comfortable to walk and call
people's Bluff I've you know I played a
lot of games where I was like willing to
walk but I was close like I want 130
they want to pay me in 110 and I'm
holding and I walk and they also walk in
like that I could probably did want to
take the 110 like you take some elves
along the way but that's the game so so
how do you transcend that right like you
know that's fine I'm okay I understand
you know I have to be I do have the
stomach to take some losses which I do I
absolutely do but then how so then how
this is another part because that was my
original question and there was a few
days ago and then I kind of watched you
and I heard you talk and I was like well
I know the answer you know already but
and how do I because I know that I'm
really gifted right and in talking to
people and in expressing their vision
and and how do we how do I myself
personally and
so within my company which is just a
creative collective between myself and
my friend Jenna she's an excellent
artist - how do we take what we're doing
and transcend it you know like we did
some really cool stuff what does
transcend mean do you mean get people
coming to you instead are you going to
them not necessarily treat send me okay
I'm saying like you know so we do we do
some really cool art installations you
know locally like we both we live in
Miami we're both from Cleveland Ohio
originally but we live in Miami Florida
so we do so we've done some cool stuff
there you know but it's like it's cool
but how do I take I think both of our
personalities and both of our passions
for art and and become more famous that
so people really want you and pay you
more to do installations I just want to
define transcend I need to know what the
[ __ ] that means okay
yes that's yes absolutely okay good how
much content are you making we should be
making more but we make really beautiful
great I don't give a [ __ ] I need you to
post four seven thirteen 23 times a day
across five platforms YouTube Facebook
Twitter like it's called the Internet I
know it's called social media it's been
going on but yes fine like it's it's not
going anywhere it's forever it matters
more every single day there used to be
real models that maybe came in sort of
models there used to be real comedians
now there's this [ __ ] ship has sailed
mm-hmm you have to post [ __ ] content
and then eventually one [ __ ] right
person sees your installation in [ __ ]
Berlin while they're going through there
explore page and like this [ __ ] fresh
they DM you and your life changes I do
not understand why people don't
understand this game because they're
insecure when they post something gets
87 likes oh my god I'm like people open
oh so [ __ ] post I know
gene I'm super-pumped you got the
stomach for the conception you don't
care so good you're set don't [ __ ] do
all right love you thank you you're
welcome
some good that was some like Cleveland
Jersey [ __ ] that was some East Coast
that was it
eastcoast conversation you know that was
definitely an East Coast conversation
that wasn't some Malibu [ __ ] you know
you know healthy tea [ __ ] that was some
[ __ ] dirty tea in Jersey and
Cleveland [ __ ] I liked it that's how I
like the [ __ ] go sometimes mm-hmm
clean what's good good man how are ya
really well were you at Oakville Ontario
Canada about 25 miles outside Toronto
let's go first of all thank you so much
for all that you do man honestly you've
been a huge inspiration motivator it's
been it's been about three or four years
since I started listening to you thank
you so much clean yeah of course I'm in
a wheelchair with muscular dystrophy and
oh I love you for that
so it's you know claim it's so funny I
apologize for interrupting you but you
uh you just motivated me so much because
I know 10,000 people are watching right
now and and they're sitting there
worried about dumb [ __ ] and just your
[ __ ] mind set on such you know you
know that's a tough hand and for you to
be able to I said to my mom and dad this
morning before I want to show some life
is about what you look like
life is about perspective life is
completely based on what you're looking
for you find what you're looking for if
you're looking for happiness and
optimism it's there if you're looking
for negativity and pessimism it's there
somebody literally right before he came
on complain that they can't go to the
gym that they're used to or get their
favorite coffee shop and like I just
appreciate you bro I really do thank you
I really appreciate that so I'm
currently I'm I did a social media
marketing course just the basic one just
to get you know my feet on the ground
mind the puns since I'm in a chair but
anyway the wheels rolling right and I'm
currently in the process of getting
guests whatnot I want to do a blog or a
interview like you know athletes
musicians other disabled people
and get their perspective on you know
what they've done with charities what
they've done with people with
disabilities and yes I'm just wondering
how do you recommend that I make the
interviews interesting instead of you
know I don't want to go like news anchor
half and just be blast [ __ ] I want ask
ask [ __ ] interesting questions start
it you know now I come to your show I
know what you're about I know what this
shows about and your opening question is
about the first you know who you know
let's say it's a 44 year old athlete and
you ask them who who do you think was
hotter Cindy Crawford or Jessica Rabbit
right I'll ask them what their favorites
you know who their favorite athlete is
and why and you dig in like interesting
as [ __ ] is completely based on the
interviewer it's based on your
creativity right right there is how do i
how do I recommend you do it ask random
ask questions that most people don't ask
while asking the four or five questions
they ask that's it it's some left-field
[ __ ] I'm an interesting interviewer I
bug the [ __ ] out of people because I
interrupt so much but I already know
what the question I know what the
person's saying and I'm trying to move
it so like some people hate it but one
thing that I've noticed is a big
undertone of people that love it because
a lot of people that I have on have done
87 other podcasts and they've heard all
the same [ __ ] but when they come on my
show I'm throwing such little [ __ ]
curveballs jumping in interrupting I'm
getting some new [ __ ] from them so
that's why I'm an interesting
interviewer but a lot of people hate it
because I'm interrupting right they
wanted to hear that person's thought
because they didn't understand where
they were going
I respect that I just that's who I am as
an interviewer you clay and you need to
be yourself as an interviewer you want
to be more interesting think of
interesting questions do research right
right because I took my took journalism
were way back I you know I took it I
didn't really like the whole background
of journalism like they're just telling
you what their platform wants you to
tell them and I want I want to go my own
way and just you know make it
interesting I don't want to be mean what
to do yeah I got I mean of course well
school tells you I mean that bro
yeah and I went through you know I went
through a bad breakup I was depressed
for a few years but then when I
discovered you three years ago you were
just like you know [ __ ] it go for it do
it like you just need to start posting
you you don't know people always assume
that they're gonna be [ __ ] at something
or they won't people all the people are
people sick no people say no because I
just say yes to everything everybody
rags no no safe takes courage B's
actually yeah and that's why like I've
been spamming everybody like I've
iMessage Justin Bieber for God's sake
like I don't want to get some
interesting people on there and for you
if the worst can happen is they don't
respond like I never said he'll let me
let me give you let me give you a good
piece of advice if you're going through
DMS really pay attention to the last
five or six posts see what they're up to
and try to start the conversation with
something that brings the damn value
versus brings you value when people like
yo Gary B be on my show you know like
you know you know when they've got four
listeners I'm in charity mode and
ironically I love doing that [ __ ] I've
done a lot couple years ago I actually
did a [ __ ] podcast every day for the
year just to put people on I still say
yes to small things but look at their
profile and try to figure out something
of their value right right and that's
just that's got other yeah if you bring
value in the opening DM you've got a
much better shot than just ctrl-c ctrl-v
do you want to be on my podcast that's
right that's the lazy way out spending
three minutes on somebody is way better
than three seconds when you're trying to
get somebody who's [ __ ] up there you
know what yeah yeah yeah and you're good
what would your recommendation be like
I'm thinking IG TV but I've you know
I've made a Twitter I've made a face IG
TV is very good bigger audience I think
IG TVs a good start don't overthink this
option posting it on YouTube tube
probably is not either right just go for
it
I want the content everywhere you start
at one hug then you strip the video from
IG TV and then you [ __ ] post it
everywhere right right
okay and just make a contextual awesome
brother I wish you welcome right thanks
so much you're welcome
kill yourself lay down some good stuff
good stuff Santa thank you so much let's
go
Dallas Barnes clay and if you're still
watching Dallas Barnes is in my in my
[Music]
Twitter feed talking that he also has
muscular dystrophy so wanted to connect
with you good morning good morning
what's your name are you Meggie Solomon
Reggie it's such a pleasure where you
from very nice what's good originally
from Jersey so all that Jersey talk well
my family's all in Morris Plains
Morristown area I'm from Flemington I
went you know I went to North hundred in
high school no way I went to hundred in
central I know rival who's watching
literally on this one little highway in
rural New Jersey it's like 11 minutes
away or high school so pretty cool
go ahead that's awesome that's awesome
so I I have actually been very
successful my career I have been
healthcare IT since I graduated college
and I always say health crises when were
in a recession health care is constantly
booming but and financially it's always
been well but I have always had a
passion a little bit about my background
is that I my mom introduced me at Tony
Robbins when I was in fifth grade I mean
I was listening to that stuff always you
know she made me believe I could fly
yeah I mean but but it wasn't just
motivation it was believing it and
feeling it and I'm very big on energy
it's too huge on energy so I I have been
meditating lately and I have found that
you know I like my job I love my job I
like what I do I'm really good at it
but it's not my purpose and I know my
purpose is I feel like I have a voice
and I need to be utilizing it and I need
to do something with it it's it's in the
voices good news good news you know
Tony back and then they needed money to
run all those infomercials to build his
brand
the 80s right we have something called
the Internet and it's great but I don't
know how where to start so I feel that
anyway something just something that I'm
really passionate about speaking about
is I feel like we we inherit limiting
beliefs and that's something people and
so but it's it's mind-boggling when I
see parents and the way they talk to
their kids and there's no one no one
educating these kids on how they can
transform their lives and I feel like
that's something that when I'm able to
show come on ready it's ready yep hang
up here go start a tick tock account and
spit your truth for a minute and post it
do you feel that I mean so I don't know
if I'm my own limiting beliefs are
getting in the way of course it is of
course this is like the funniest meta
conversation of all time Maggie you're
telling everybody else the problem
you're in it right this second yeah I'm
happy I'm like happy because I'm like oh
this is gonna be fun like I was watching
you walk down this path like this is
gonna be fun I can't wait to jump out me
like do you know like like like yes what
you're asking everybody else to do is
what you're struggling with you're
worried about the judgement of that post
yeah
that's why you've been playing it so
safe that [ __ ] feelings been inside
of you you didn't [ __ ] meditate that
out in last month you could think of
this [ __ ] from the get well because
social media has always been something I
had it posted like personal things I've
always keep my social media private and
so I know it's safe social media is no
different than your [ __ ] IT job you
can play in the [ __ ] safe Meggy so so
how do you is it tick tock or do you how
do you separate that from your your
personal like your your job you know I'm
a professor working professional and you
know I'm a professional too nobody gives
a [ __ ]
yeah also by the way it's not like
you're gonna be making [ __ ] naked
videos you're gonna [ __ ] talk good
[ __ ] it's not like I read oh you're
gonna walk in and be like Miss
Jones you're bossing me like Meggie I
didn't like you trying to inspire those
kids on social security numbers like so
someone who you have an ideology you
have an ideology of a professional that
you need to break as well
yeah well that I been working on myself
but something that a keynote speaker
here in South Florida she's pretty big
and one thing she told me was find
someone who's doing what you want to be
doing and go to the top what is the best
you know I'm still waiting for Oprah
Winfrey to call me back but go to the
best and member you but I don't know if
that have [ __ ] that have the world
mentor you you don't need a mentor you
need to make a [ __ ] video don't pay
somebody [ __ ] $40,000 to give you
courage I'm gonna give it to you right
now for free maybe what's maybe this is
you remember when you were like scared
to like have your first kiss or to swim
or to ride a bike or to take the SATs
this is all the same [ __ ] just do what's
gonna happen [ __ ] sick talk video and
be like kids
I'm Meggie I've been seeing a lot of
[ __ ] here's what I see parents just
saying no I think it's yes today next
next next I mean [ __ ] hundreds of
videos before anybody gave a [ __ ] good
talk good talk
thank you so much when I wish you
continued abundance and success I really
do
god bless you talk to you soon god bless
you too take them this is a [ __ ] good
day these Jersey girls get me going
you know Jersey Ohio I love this [ __ ] I
[ __ ] really get into it Shawn Smith
it is better late than never boom
landing City New Jersey you were in the
mix thank you Peter for saying what you
just said I like being generous
John what's good eye--you your audio but
I don't see your video now we see it
good morning John how are you not too
bad good so while the other day you were
talking about not to put up
odds and the real you so my question was
what if you are the real you 110 percent
of the time and that's why I think maybe
don't maybe people don't want to work
with you because of who you are then
maybe then maybe you want to change and
actually work on it like no different
than physical or mental like I've made
changes I've had to become more
radically I have I've had to be more
Candice John because people love working
with me because I kept in all my
negative feelings about them for 20
years and I wouldn't share and then I
would just stun them and fire them and
then they would be really mad at me like
oh [ __ ] wait a minute I'm [ __ ] this
up so I've had a change I've been better
and it's still work in progress for you
but I've been better at giving negative
feedback because I love positivity and
all that [ __ ] on the flip side I watched
my dad who was very difficult on his
employees after I came in and showed it
for math he evolved he evolved I
listened to him talking to an employee
last night on the phone and he'd the way
he talked them like well that you know
my mom even said it too because I was
listening she's like you starting to
sound like Gary it's like a hobby like
you know being your authentic self is
amazing but if your authentic self
is not kind or is condescending or is in
general half glass empty or scared it's
going to rub people the wrong way and
that becomes a game of you now starting
to work on oneself which is amazing yeah
over the years I have evolved into the
I'm sure you have back in the day I was
a lot worse and I live in a smaller
community that's why this has been an
issue is because everybody everyone
reputation yeah so I'd like I said I
have evolved I'm a professional tattoo
artist so you know it's all local all my
business is local you know so that that
kind of it's kind of a problem I like I
like where you're going I like where you
going I can give you some real [ __ ] if
I'm and honestly bro I'm not joking I'm
getting the goosebumps I'm telling you
right now and this is now almost two
weeks of this show this might be my
favorite one John listen to me listen to
me carefully if you make a Facebook and
Instagram Twitter video video you can
put them all on the same platforms and
you literally make a one-minute video or
five-minute video and put on YouTube and
Twitter or whatever or IG TV and you
literally say
what's the town's name I'm in Hibbing
Minnesota Hibbing lubing yep I'm not
even joking Hibbing what's good it's
John listen you know whether it's the
quarantine whether it's just been this
was the inevitable end of this road
weather was me talking to my guy garyvee
last week I'm making this video a couple
things [ __ ] sorry about some stuff in
the past I'm [ __ ] grown up now like
that dumb [ __ ] I did three years ago -
Uncle John I [ __ ] up I was in a bad
place my childhood put me in a place
where I was insecure I was scared but
I'm evolving and I want you to know that
and I'm putting this [ __ ] flag in the
ground to say listen you guys know
Hibbing in a small town we all have our
reps everybody knows everything but I'm
putting this flag in the ground right
now
to change that I want I want to be
different I have become different I have
a lot of regrets and sorry's I want to
put out there but today is a fresh day
and I'm not living backwards I can't
dwell I'm going forward and I just want
you to know that so if you see me in the
supermarket if you see me in the
restaurant or if he's scared to come in
here because you don't want to deal with
some of the [ __ ] that I was about in
the past
it's a [ __ ] fresh slate please and so
thank you I hope I see you I also will
go out of my way if I see you at the
coffee shop and say what's up it's a
fresh day we need so much more
positivity in the world and I'm [ __ ]
starting that for me now I don't just
inspire some of you to do this as well
there's nothing more powerful than
saying I'm sorry and I'm ready for a
change make that video and your whole
[ __ ] life will be different
I'm telling you right now you drop that
and the deeper truth you go you notice
how in my little may pretend video I
said something about Uncle John or you
know like if there's something specific
like I'm serious about this bro having
the humility and the courage to make the
video I just said is a game-changer of
happiness for you and everybody around
you yeah I'm da word I mean I'm a little
nervous like even right now I don't like
look it's scary it's scary I love that
so also I read here cuz the same day I
was thinking about this [ __ ] I was like
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do about this
you don't so I decided well no every
year I got this [ __ ] time on my hands
so I went onto my garage I cleaned it
out and all I'm building a paint booth
so I can start painting motorcycles and
[ __ ] you know just a sign that [ __ ]
gone you know you're clearly a very
intimate yeah and you're clearly a very
talented creative dude with your hands
in your mind it's [ __ ] fresh John
listen to me we're all evolving we all
have regrets
we all have sorry's you have the courage
to make that video it's game-changing
I'll do it I kind of think you might
that's why I think I got the goose bumps
I kind of knew what I needed to say and
I kind of bro please hit me up because I
don't I don't think you understand after
you do this how much I could sense your
humanity and kindness I think you have
regrets and and I think when you get
that out you're gonna be [ __ ] happy
bro
absolutely absolutely thank you very
much you're welcome very much hey could
I could I say one more thing you can't
there was a fella on here you told him
to create a logo if he's still watching
that let him be a breeze
yes grot one three two and I'll hook yo
G ro t13 - got it
rot13 - everybody's watching right now
go on Instagram go to his latest post go
to grot one three two and go encourage
him to make this [ __ ] video and
require it to be on his Instagram within
the next I'll give him 48 hours go put
on the man here let's go push Johnny
grot grot one three two go on there
right now Boehner nation and pressure
this man see ya thank you it's a good
one Dustin it's a good show big
shout-out to read it for the small
community that's watching there we're
testing that out big shout out to the
first in line group love it
Michael what's good no the day in
paradise I agree how you doing limit
what can i what can I answer for you
yeah so I'm down here in Virginia
Culpepper Virginia so what kind of small
town about 60,000 people and I own a
CrossFit boutique gym instead yeah so a
lot of a lot of the stuff that we do and
a lot of owners just in this kind of
market tend to rely on social media
Instagram Facebook Twitter things like
that yeah with me being a local gym the
audience that I'm able to reach is is
kind of tapped out I would say it's
tapped out there's always room for I get
it
it's definitely not tapped out but I get
it yeah so a lot of what's happened over
this past year is we got a massive
Planet Fitness coming in we got Gold's
jam and then we got a local back gym as
well all the supply and demand right now
there's yeah gyms there's only so many
people in the area now it's gotten
tighter understood CrossFit itself has
evolved from a super hot brand you know
eight ten years ago to probably a more
leveled played out you know it's not an
it's white-hot moment correct yeah yeah
so all these guys aren't my direct
competitors right they still saturate
the market with you know advertising and
billboards and and they they've got
millions of dollars to just dump and
throw money at advertising and mail
boxes which I don't and the good news is
they don't you know I know enough about
Planet Fitness and gold's they don't
they have enough money when they first
come in to drop some real money to
establish but that will tail off as well
but keep going so my main concern is
like I have money that I could probably
do flyers and I could put yard sale
signs and things like that but for me to
dump my money on a kind of a hope right
hope this works hope this works
yeah and I know social media works right
and we get the biggest bang and return
for our but but I'm looking at you know
this year especially 2020 I need more
ground more
so I've got to figure out that's so real
quick real quick real quick you know how
somebody comes to CrossFit and like you
know it's a pretty intense framework you
know how some people are better at it
than others but just better better form
know how to keep themselves not from
getting hurt have better intensity
better mindset right you've seen a lot
of people come through it right I'm
gonna say this right now you need to
hear this if you do Facebook marketing
800 different pictures in a small town
sixty thousand eight hundred different
pictures eight hundred different targets
for do you understand that if you made a
Facebook ad that said are you 42 to 44
years old and you targeted people in
your town that are 42 to 44 years old
and then you made a piece of content
about something that made sense that
that would crush any [ __ ] yard sale
Direct Mail local billboard there's no
better platform in the world
local marketing than Facebook the
difference is I'm the best person in the
CrossFit gym in doing that and you're
not there yet and I want to get you
there listen to me on a town of 60,000
people I think you need a hundred to two
hundred different pictures and videos to
run ads for in your town can you imagine
right now Michael every single person
that's in the same situation is you
watching saying oh [ __ ] I only have one
ad I run they treat Facebook like a
[ __ ] direct mail piece or a billboard
or a TV commercial or a radio spot they
don't use the platform properly you know
how people say you forget CrossFit
everyone gets hurt you're like not if
you do it right yeah well guess what I'm
telling you the same [ __ ] right now it's
marketing if you put an african-american
and a woman in the in the video and
target african-americans in your town
it's gonna convert better if you put in
University of Virginia [ __ ] t-shirt
in there and target that Burt alums of
UV and then BT forbid like do you
understand yeah and I think that's what
I've been doing so we've been we've been
doing right telling stories and spot
focusing certain organic organic but
what I haven't done and I've realized
this year is I haven't I haven't
targeted specific markets like you're
talking about and I
relighted let me give you an example
give me a town that you so you got this
big town but then give me a town or a
subsection or the hills give me like a
verbage of a little subsection that you
would love to get more customers from
cuz it's a little further away or it's
high-net-worth give me something are you
looking for results can't find them I
apologize I apologize tell me the town
like give me the actual name yeah
Madison Virginia Madison so what's
really important is now lesson for
everybody is the first three seconds of
the video so here's here's my thing
Madison Madison it's me Michael first of
all Big Ups well berries are good by the
way every time I'm down the block in
Madison I go into Joe's cheesesteak
house that [ __ ] [ __ ] is crazy
that stuff is crazy by the way mattis
listenmi my name is Michael I own this
right this cross come in say hello to me
like first next ready watch this
Madison it's me Michael big shout out to
all the UVM fair you know
Virginia Tech you know Virginia Union
alum come through walk in look for me in
the gym and say Virginia Union and the
first month of my gym is free don't tell
don't tell the University of Virginia
Virginia do [ __ ] yeah okay and that's
the thing I haven't been direct
targeting so I mean so you guess what
ready ready what you've been doing with
organic is like not using your legs when
you're [ __ ] try to do a squat you
know what I mean like I'm just using my
arm you're [ __ ] doing it wrong Lucas
by yeah man I'm excited
you know this energy is I'm excited for
you you gonna be blown you'd be like
there's me a [ __ ] poster of me and
your [ __ ] gym once you figure this
out Facebook and Instagram local
targeting contextual targeting tons of
different creative towards the micro
targets will change your life little
interesting things like come in find me
in the gym say Virginia Union first
month little [ __ ] like that do you a
serve any beverages or
thing like that like it's local like
recovery drinks things like that love
that you know you make it out and say
listen you come in you find me you say
that you saw this on Facebook you find
me when you sign up I'm always there
maybe you not maybe are where you find
the manager I don't I don't know the
details and you say that you saw this on
Facebook when you sign up for the
membership and all our recovery drinks
for the first month free like just do
[ __ ] hustle yeah that's money
I'm telling you brother I know what I'm
talking about yeah people are funny
people people drive to Wine Library for
a free piece of bread that's [ __ ] 19
cents from 31 minutes a wet way because
some people are just wired to love three
people are literally gonna be right next
door to Gold's Gym see your [ __ ] on
Facebook and literally sign up for a
one-year membership with you because
they got [ __ ] seven [ __ ] energy
drinks for free
yeah and that's what's kind of hard as I
don't I don't want the clientele that
wants $20 a month and free right so it's
been kind of hard I respect that yeah I
respect that I think that you shouldn't
say no for the other people you may say
to me Gary they're the exact same person
that cancels after a month I say I
respect that but if you get one month
out of them for a $13 Facebook ad and
you see where I'm going brother and by
the way you said I like how you reacted
it's all about how much it costs to get
them in if it cost you a thousand and
they quit after a month your [ __ ] if it
costs you $13 because Facebook's a
[ __ ] beast and now you're using it
right and in the first [ __ ] month
they pay you back and you're almost a
house money at that point you're gonna
change your [ __ ] tune yeah money by
numbers right that's right dropping some
serious knowledge Dustin I mean we just
did a [ __ ] local there are literally
people that sell [ __ ] Facebook local
business courses for a [ __ ] 200 bucks
that just got clowned on in that four
and a half minutes of [ __ ] rent
Jessica what's good it's happening I'm
so excited oh my goodness Gary thank you
thank you thank you first and foremost I
came across her content
it wasn't even your content actually I
was listening to
Breakfast Club 105 one you were talking
about your 400 trillion to one and I was
literally like sitting in my car and I'm
I was pregnant with my third my third
baby I have four kids a dog thank you
and my fabulous husband who like
supports me and everything I do I'm
sorry I feel like I'm gonna cry and so
I'm sitting there and I'm going and I'm
going off on breakfast club and you are
like you are totally they can't hit a
hit and I'm like yes Jerry yes I can't I
can't keep doing this [ __ ] anymore
and I what I was doing at the time I was
a I was a court reporter for five years
and then I did cart providing for the
last two so I basically captioned for
the Deaf and hearing-impaired students
at a school in New Jersey and I I
absolutely like loved being around the
kids loved what I did but we ended up
moving further away and it was just like
it just didn't work out
so at the time that I'm listening to you
on the radio I'm like yes I want to do
something else I want to do something
different and I had my my uncle who's in
real estate and I saw how busy his
business was and how much he did in a
day so I was like hey let me be your
virtual assistant like let me like I
kind of made that my side hustle and I
was like alright I'm gonna I'm gonna go
to you know car I'm gonna car provide
during the day and then I'll virtual
assist him you know in the afternoon and
at night and I did that and I'm still
doing that but I also started dabbling
in like social media and and in that
whole realm and I I really do enjoy the
social media aspect of things and like
building people's content and stuff like
that but I'm I'm I like totally
resonated with I believe like Amanda was
her name she was on maybe like two days
ago and you were like ah she's like
you're like a renaissance woman and I
was like oh my god this is so me I have
like so many different passions I feel
like in so many different things that I
want to do and I'm like not
sure you always talk about happiness and
so um I'm always like okay like does
this really make me happy is this really
what I want to do there's a good news
there's good news if it does at the
moment that's good and if it doesn't a
week later and it doesn't it's okay
right it's all about judgment on oneself
it's not like you have to figure out the
thing that's gonna make you happy
forever you figure out the thing that's
gonna make you happy today right right
right right
so the one thing that truly makes me
happy is being with my kids like I want
to be there like that was my main thing
I was like I don't care what I do as
long as I can pick them up from school
and work on homework with them every day
that's what I do so to this day I've
been able to do that and I'm so grateful
for that because my parents my parents
hustled like all the time they were they
were to grow up in North Bergen and
Fairview New Jersey no way ya know in
Phillipsburg New Jersey oh my god yeah
do you want do you want to hear
something crazy what the first baseball
card show I ever did was in the filter
of ball I mean it was a [ __ ] mall when I
was a kid and now there's only like four
of the 400 stores now it's it's horrible
it's a horrible it's falling apart at
the moment but uh but yeah so and
actually then I started like learning
more about you and I was like from
Springfield you sound just like my uncle
he's like my favorite person in the
world or one of my favorite people in
the world and I'm always like uncle Eric
he told like you totally sound like Gary
B and when I found out like Springfield
I'm like oh like that's where you grew
up
lookit I'm like there's so many
similarities anyway so like my my
question is is I'm not sure if I should
continue with social media and starting
an agency or the the other thing that I
have going on right now is I'm like
actually my family and I we were like in
a lot of debt never any like stupid or
frivolous spending on like dumb [ __ ] we
have four kids
I went to school in the beginning I
don't know we use our credit cards for a
lot of [ __ ] like groceries and diapers
and all that stuff and we just realized
like my husband died were like we can't
we can't [ __ ] be here like we can't
be here for the rest of our lives like
we got to do something
so I've I created an Instagram page and
basically started talking about why is
that why you moved to Pittsburgh cuz
like the pricing is so good right yeah
we got it
we got such a great deal on our home
we've never stayed in like Bergen County
or anything like there was none so we're
up here we have you know space for the
family the kids love it we have a nice
big yard it's awesome but we're also
like super duper focused on our budget
and super like you know paying things
off getting trying to get money in the
bank this [ __ ] hit and we were like wow
like this is what it feels like to have
like some savings right in the bank and
not feel like you're gonna lose your
[ __ ] mind because you know that
payment have you ever considered
flipping so we were talking about it
like I've seen your garage you know all
the garage the whole like Bethlem
Township Pennsylvania Phillipsburg this
area right load is loaded I know and
like so my husband and I were like
alright we're gonna do this on the
weekends it's gonna be like a family
thing we're gonna go like together and
like teach the kids how to like hustle
too and know it's like it was totally
like a recent thing and we saw one of
your videos you were like being driven
in like a Oberer or something and the
guy was originally yes and I was like
come on like let's go and yeah this
thing's gonna be eventually over okay
it's like thrift stores there's a bunch
of little thrift stores yeah there
you're in a really nice little area to
pick up some stuff like I this is an
area that I've gotten to work on for the
last 20 years like there's a lot of
opportunity for you on that I think
you're gonna do really well with it I
love the family dynamic
one of those four kids two of those four
kids are gonna really learn some [ __ ]
because I'm just in them it's gonna be
good memories my favorite memories one
of my favorite memories in my life is
where my brother and I did that when he
was like 12 13 14 15 like 6 o'clock in
the morning getting a doughnut together
and just kind of go in like so I think
it would be great okay and do you think
so I've been very like hesitant to post
that type like content with our family
like with our kids I'll share anything
in my personal life so I think that you
can maintain that you don't need to show
that part right and I've gone I've gone
garage son with Xander on Sanders with
me when we do trash talk you just don't
know it you just right we don't see but
if we if we wanted to like I I hear you
all the time like dude like it's okay
like but like you know like it's not
like super dangerous for kids to be on
and exposed and all that stuff like my
daughter has an Instagram page for her
soccer
she's like a very passionate soccer
player and I post stuff but again like
we don't share locations we don't share
anything yeah you're in charge you know
how to get your kids you know which kid
is a dope and you don't want them to do
it at first you know which ones
responsible and right younger my oldest
daughter was still the second the second
kid she has Instagram because I'm like
yeah and girls gravitate to social a
little bit earlier than guys to just you
know women mature faster yeah yeah yeah
I mean my son's on tik-tok so there's
that but he joined the whole wave before
any of us did so okay so garage yes
first of all I love your energy which is
why I didn't like keeping you on the
whole time thank you
I think the garage don't think is gonna
work for you I don't know why but I
[ __ ] feel and I can't wait to see a
random tweet from you in a year being
like Gary Vee it happened - as far as
the social media agency or doing your
own content as like The Frugal stuff or
like the receipts of the interest both
just keep tasting keep working keep
working don't overthink it just do don't
dwell you know operate don't overthink
just make make make you know
and and and what happens is when you're
in that model eventually something is so
clear that you then become that do you
understand
plus you're happy plus your biggest ROI
is really just being there for your kids
so I love the garage sale thing I'll be
very honest with you the flippin thing
is money you understand you're gonna go
- you're gonna go to one house in Easton
in a town-wide sale in the fall and and
you're gonna start getting educated and
you're gonna spend twenty eight bucks
and it's gonna be three thousand yeah
there's a trash talk if you go watch all
five trash talks I did there's one flash
talk episode where I buy $20 worth
Olympic pins ended up being like $1,300
okay yep plus some of the stuff it's
interesting is if you really get good a
thrift stores and there's a bunch in
that kind of PA New Jersey area like
then your garage sale in every day then
you're you know now all of a sudden you
know while your kids are at school you
go in a Goodwill spending 17 bucks
coming home and it's 137 the next week
you know like it's real [ __ ] it's real
[ __ ] like right if you're if people are
really committed to it it's if you get
really good and you're really committed
to it it's a thirty forty sixty eighty
thousand dollar side hustle wow it's
real money yeah because you people
people who realize is almost everything
out of goodwill in a garage so is worth
more on eBay and Facebook marketplace so
you start really realizing that
sharpener running t-shirts or money you
know you don't get books like we've
picked up things they're sitting in our
garage now but like I I'm always like yo
like you see something on the [ __ ]
side of the road I'm like hey babe you
know you got you got room in your car
can you come pick this up like we have
sitting in the garage that I'm like yo
we can [ __ ] sell this but you should
post it Jess I want you to do one thing
cuz I'll get someone will call before
about that a sorry list list something
on Facebook marketplace today be like yo
you I could put out on the curb you can
come pick it up we can do social
distancing allow you to list three to
four things on Facebook marketplace that
are sitting in your garage you promise
okay yeah you know have you ever post
anything on Facebook marketplace
yeah we're yeah I have four kids I'm
constantly posting [ __ ] I'm like get
this out of my house I don't need God to
play you know I don't want God thinking
that I want any more kids I love my kids
so much before is enough all right
that's actually at the prep for this
call so we'll get to more might pop up
and do some stuff on the weekend look
for that I'll be more breaking news if I
get kinda bored here over the weekend I
might pop in but if not I will see you
Monday morning 9:00 a.m. Eastern Dustin
thank you so much to be another ones and
to big shout out to the first in line
Facebook group that we have that's
private that getting a little bit of a
watch party really appreciate everybody
sharing please hit my Twitter hard right
now with a recap of what you thought and
then finally the big plug I got you dad
the big big big plug if you buy wine on
the internet if you buy wine actually
and you like me then please love my
father
wine Tex comm link is right there it
would mean the apps of world to me it's
also crazy oh and today is a big one
because we usually play in that fifteen
to thirty five dollar range today's an
$11 white wine that blew my face off
that I tweeted about last week so I told
bran and we got to get this into wine
tech so anyway see you guys tomorrow or
Monday love you all see you soon
you